[Music]
in this week's 48 hours we're learning
more about the murder of a college
student and the key role of an apple
watch in the investigation 21 year old
ally costell she was about to enter her
senior year at the university of
mississippi when she was found dead with
multiple gunshot wounds at an abandoned
fishing camp 30 miles from campus cbs
saturday morning co-host michelle miller
is on assignment for 48 hours
allie costell loved pink her red
convertible and taking photos of sunsets
ali what are you doing taking a picture
for sunsets by alex
vaughn hemingway stadium oxford
mississippi it is the home opener for
the ole miss rebels elizabeth brock and
morgan hall met ali on campus it's fair
to say she
loved
ole miss yes ali loved ole miss
this surveillance footage captured an
image of ali walking out of a bar in
oxford square late on friday night july
19 2019 lafette county district attorney
ben creekmore she takes an uber
and she goes home alone
investigator jared bundren arrived on
the scene saturday morning after allie's
body was discovered when you got there
what did you find a white female
laying on the ground with multiple
gunshot wounds to her back
i have not worked a murder where
somebody's been shot that many times
the police came to the door
and they told us
what did they tell you
there had been a homicide in that she
was the victim allie's parents keith and
cindy costell and i still don't believe
it
here we are
investigators needed answers and they
found them at ali's apartment they
discovered text messages on her apple
watch the hardest thing to do
is to go back and read
her messages those messages will reveal
a lot more about ally costell's life and
eventually lead investigators to her
killer
in your mind the motive for murder was
get rid of a problem
michelle miller joins us right now good
morning um we communicate a lot by text
we do we're in her text messages that
are important to the investigation well
keep in mind they weren't able to get it
from this right they got it off of her
apple watch
and it led them down a path to hundreds
of text messages
the important and key point is that many
of those messages were with the person
she was with just hours before
her death
to take care of her problem was what the
prosecutor was saying yes and that's a
big question too
and gail gail hit on it what exactly was
it yeah what was that problem it's a
great tease isn't it it was a very good
tease but thank goodness again for the
apple watch there's so much information
yes you don't even realize and you know
young folks text they text a lot but
this is truly a cautionary tale not just
tragic but hopefully people will learn
something from that that's great
michelle thank you thank you you can see
michelle's report what aly costell
didn't know on 48 hours tomorrow night
at 10 9 central right here on cbs and
our streaming service paramount plus